Josh Norman jumped over a bowl your
thoughts on that yeah well I knew the
bull wouldn't hit him he's he avoids
contact just Katie Josh just kidding
groan that's hilarious and there's Josh
Norma there's nothing hilarious about
jumping over the bull that that's gutsy
from Josh Norman I have a feeling that
if he's on the team next year they will
make sure they tell him in advance do
not return to Pamplona Washington's
defensive secondary has been beefed up
by the addition of Landon Collins the
former giant and there's a lot of
acrimony there between Collins and the
Giants remember there was speculation
when they used the franchise tag they're
gonna try to sign him they just showed
no inclination at all to keep him around
Chris and he's got some lingering hard
feelings just last week he he were he
refused to refer to the Giants by name
he said there's no reason to mention
that name anymore and yesterday he was
on NFL Network he was asked what he
would do when the team's meet this
season if he sees general manager Dave
gentlemen on the field during pregame
warmups Collins said he'd looked for an
excuse to run into Gettleman I'll tell
one of my defensive back coaches throw
the ball in that direction give him a
nice little thud a little run over and
you know you know it was all said in in
good fun but deep down Collins is upset
with the Giants and the Gettleman is the
focal point but yeah this came out last
week without Oh Beckham jr. and his
article with GQ Chris the idea that
Gettleman was the one who ultimately
decided to trade OTO Beckham jr. and not
not tell Beckham ahead of time John
Mayer is fingerprints are over every
move that gets made there so if any of
these guys are gonna be mad they need to
focus one level higher I think it's Mara
who's making these big decisions and
Gettleman is just the messenger well you
know maybe I don't know exactly how that
dynamic is working out I mean hey the
Giants the Mara family they're certainly
involved and paying attention to every
little detail and move but at the same
time they've been the type of family
that's let their football people do
football stuff I mean whether it's
George Young the GM and my dad's Giants
football teams and the 80s or or Ernie
Accorsi they've never stuck their nose
in there too much I mean they know
what's going on but they're not
telling those people what to do so I
don't know but either way this is what
football players do Landon Collins yeah
he's pissed off I mean he feels
disrespected he should he's did
everything he could to be the best giant
he possibly could be played through
injuries did all that stuff they drafted
him in the first round
never complained never made excuses I
think he probably feels disrespected by
the lack of dialogue during the end of
the year it sounded like there was no
dialogue that basically he knew he
wasn't gonna be back with the Giants and
yeah he's gonna use it as motivation and
just sends a little warning shot out to
Dave gentlemen like you said it's joking
but he's also letting us all know that
that's not his favorite person in the
world either when you were warming up
prior to a game was there ever a time
where you put a little bit too much on a
pass because you saw someone on the side
that you saw someone on the sidelines
that he'd criticized you or you were
selling an old score just for whoever it
was even if it was just your dad with
his back turned do you ever do that no I
did not I never had any thoughts like
that going through my head at that point
I guess I had never had any enemies now
I mean I'd love to be out there now and
then throw some balls around there's a
lot of people what if Steve Young had
been walking down the sideline I
wouldn't do it Steve Young I have
forgiven Steve Young in fact you're
gonna like this Mike as soon as I'm at
the American Century Golf Championship
out there in Lake Tahoe right as soon as
I see Steve Young which he does this to
me every time now he apologizes without
even saying hi first off he apologizes
I'm so sorry I misspoke I did all that
yes he called me laissez-faire I get it
it's all good I don't dislike Steve
Young I have tremendous respect for the
fellow lefty quarterback so I'm not mad
at him at all for that so I wouldn't
have done that no I would not have but
first of all first of all he didn't call
you laissez-faire he's not a great
quarterback because you had a
laissez-faire up ring right now would
your dad be as charitable as you have
been with Steve Young have they mended
fences probably not no I don't know if
they I don't think my dad's like still
angry at him I don't think yeah I think
he's gotten over it but I don't know if
n C's have been mended as far as they've
talked it out or do anything like that
but you're right that he did he called
my upbringing laissez-faire and that
wasn't necessarily true but either way
I'm not mad as feeling you still don't
appreciate the full depth of the insult
he said you weren't any good well
because you had a laissez faire up
Brad's fine you know Steve Young Hall to
see what else I'm trying to I'm trying
to instigate yes I want to punch him in
the face I'm very comfortable with how I
where I grew up and were and worked and
tried to become the athlete and the
player I was trying to explain why you
weren't any good right well that wasn't
I did good after that and I was the
first to start of the year I wasn't
great but it wasn't like I was horrible
or anything
I tried yeah right thank you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports